[موسيقى]
كان شكلهم
كتير اشياء
وبركضوا
لما شفتهم اه هربت ركضت عند ماما وحضنتها
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي جنى كنت رايحه على الروضه انا
عمري خمس سنين اه انا كنت عند امي اه
وحضنتها ولفيتها انا خفت عشان لما شفت
الجهاز وخفت كتير
لما شفتهم اه هربت وركزت عند ماما وحضنتها
[موسيقى]
اسراء الشخشير امها لجمع الشخير
ساكنين بنابلس بالبلده القديمه جنى
الشخصيه زي كل بنت الصبح بتسحبها تجهز
لروضتها حطيت لها سندويشتها الروضه
النوتيلا اللي بتحبها ولبستها وجهزتها
وجنى نزلت على الروضه زي كل يوم زي ما
بتنزل كل يوم دخلت على غرفتي فبتطلع اللي
بتفاجئ انه جيش
فبحكي جنى وين ما بعرف جنى اذا وصلت
الروضه مع وصلت الروضه مش عارفه وين جنى
ما الها كمان نازله يعني
فبعديها عمالها بتدق الباب بصير بخاف كثير
قوي وفتحت الباب
خايفه كتير كتير بتحكي لي ماما الجيش وراي
الجيش لقيتهم بوجهي وانا طلعت فهارب راجعه
البيت ركض
ولا هي اجت لفيتها وشربتها ميه وقعدتها
يعني
ومصدومه يعني من اللي شافتهم من كثر الجيش
اللي شافته مش عارفه ايش بدها تعبر ايش
بدها تحكي لي
[موسيقى]
انا لما شفت الفيديو حكيت لهم جنى جنى
ابوها ما عرفها ابوها ما عرف انها جنى انا
من من شاعرها من دبسها من كل اشي يعني
حكيت لو اني انا مكانها لجنى أدب ما خفت
كتير كنت مرعوبه ومتوتره
متعوده كل يوم الصبح تطلع عادي على وجهتها
فتفاجات انه اول ما طلعت
كميه الجيش اللي اجت
مش مسترجع اني اطلعهم صرت مكان اني خلص ما
راح اخليهم يطلعوا مدارس ولا اخليهم يضلوا
عندي بصراحه ما في امان نهائيا
صرتي بدهم يطلعوا الصبح تكون كتير خايفه
بدهم
بترويحه تخافي ما بتعرفي اي وقت بيدخلوا
الجيش صار ما بتعرفي كيف بدخلوا ما بتعرفي
الطريقه اللي هم متعودين صاروا يدخلوا
فيها صار كتير خاف عنا ما عنا امان
[موسيقى]
من حقهم هدول الاطفال الصغار من حقهم انهم
يطلعوا الصبح زيهم زي اي طفل زيهم زي اي
مكان يحقق كل احلامهم مش مش يطلعوا انه
يتفاجئوا انه جيش بوجههم انه يخافوا
يطلعوا اولادها وتكون مطمن عليهم مش انه
يكون على اعصابه
[موسيقى]
انا بحب اروح على الروضه او بحب العب معهم
اصحابي ما بدي اروح على الروضه لحالي لازم
بابا وماما ياخذونا انا بخاف اروح على
الروضه لحالي
[موسيقى]